[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a 5 minutos con aquí
en france 24 se cumple un mes del
terremoto de magnitud 7.2 en haití que
dejó al menos 2.000 muertos en el sur de
ese país 30 días después miles de
personas siguen durmiendo a la
intemperie después del sismo y posterior
paso de la tormenta grave el acceso a
las zonas más afectadas continúa siendo
difícil debido a los daños a la
infraestructura lo que dificulta la
entrega de ayuda humanitaria el
terremoto revivió los recuerdos del del
año 2020 que dejó más de 3000 fallecidos
y se registró cuando el país aún no se
recuperaba del embate del huracán
matthew que dejó más de mil muertos
además cuando haití atraviesa una crisis
política tras el asesinato del
presidente yo en el movice el pasado 7
de julio el domingo el gobierno interino
y la oposición acordaron formar un
gobierno de unidad y también redactar
una nueva constitución
para analizar la situación de haití
salud en este momento a lucia el lazo
jefa de operación de emergencia de la
federación internacional de la cruz roja
en haití lucia gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 empiezo por
preguntarle cuál es el balance un mes
del terremoto en haití
bueno la situación en haití continúa
siendo bastante complicada
como has dicho muy bien las personas
siguen estando afectadas y siguen
buscando esperando ayuda humanitaria sin
embargo
continuamos trabajando sin parar hemos
logrado alcanzar hasta el momento unas
25.000 personas ya con una asistencia
para hogares lonas kits de higiene kits
de cocina que les ayuda por lo menos a
tratar de mantener una dignidad humana
mientras logran recuperarse del todo las
familias están tanto en las zonas
urbanas como las zonas rurales tienen
problemas para el acceso al agua también
estamos trabajando en este sentido
tratar de proveer agua a familias en
distintas partes y como también ha
pasado han tenido daños de
infraestructura de todo tipo tanto de
las escuelas como de las clínicas
necesitamos también trabajar mucho la
parte de salud porque hay un riesgo
también de enfermedades transmitidas por
agua ya por ende ese tipo de problemas
entonces la situación continúa
la ayuda humanitaria está avanzando es
lento
pero progresa esta es un poco el mensaje
también que queremos dar y lucia también
la parte de seguridad con las pandillas
también en varias ocasiones en varias
zonas y regiones de haití sobre todo del
sur del país la más afectada por este
terremoto que impide de alguna manera
que estas ayudas lleguen a los más
necesitados o lucia pero con tantas
tragedias ocurridas en ese país le
pregunto cuál es el sentir de los
haitianos en las calles cómo se sienten
emocionalmente cuál ha sido el impacto
de todo lo que ha ocurrido en el país en
la población
pues como te podrás imaginar
hay mucho sufrimiento hay mucha
frustración mucho miedo pero al final el
trabajo importante es alcanzar a las
comunidades hablar con las comunidades
constantemente hablar con los líderes
comunitarios con distintas personas
explicar todo lo que se está trabajando
todo lo que está sucediendo es ser muy
claros en qué es lo que se va a hacer
cómo en cómo se puede alcanzar a ellos
para que no para que sientan que no
están abandonados que seguimos ahí hay
una fuerte presencia no solamente sí de
la presencia de ayuda internacional pero
también de actores locales con lo cual
obviamente nosotros trabajamos que
trabajamos muy de cerca con la cruz roja
haitiana que tiene voluntarios en todas
las comunidades aquí lo importante es
siempre mantener una línea de
comunicación muy abierta con ellos para
explicar lo que está sucediendo y buscar
soluciones conjuntas porque al final los
problemas de acceso por la
infraestructura los problemas de acceso
por el tema de seguridad
trabajando con las comunidades siempre
se puede
y solventar estos problemas así es lucía
desde aquí a bogotá le mandamos un
abrazo para la labor que ustedes cumplen
en haití que no debe ser nada fácil le
conversábamos con lucía al lazo lucía
hasta una próxima oportunidad
bueno hasta luego luz y ahora si
llegamos al final de 5 minutos con un
france24 continué con nosotros aquí en
este canal porque hay mucho más para ver
[Música]